[Música]
cada 18 de septiembre se celebra el día
mundial de la limpieza donde se unirá a
más de 20 millones de personas en 180
países en torno a este objetivo en este
día los voluntarios y socios mundiales
se van a reunir de nuevo para librar
nuestro planeta de la basura limpiando
los desechos de nuestros playas ríos
bosques y también las calles en las
ciudades el día mundial de la limpieza
surgió en estonia cuyos habitantes en el
año 2008 decidieron tomar en sus manos
la limpieza de sus hogares entendiendo
por su hogar toda la nación les llevó
cinco horas pero al final toda la
historia estaba libre de basura y su
pueblo mucho más unido por ello quiero
saludar en este momento a mauro porcel a
ls director para américa latina y el
caribe de let's with world la energía
ambiental que organiza cada tercer
sábado de septiembre este día mundial de
la limpieza gracias a mauro por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que
consiste este evento y que balance nos
pueden entregar de años anteriores
raúl muy buenos días es un placer para
mí estar aquí contigo con todos ustedes
el balance por supuesto que es positivo
como decimos desde el ex david world que
organiza todos los terceros sábados de
septiembre el día mundial de limpieza es
educar mediante la acción estamos viendo
justo en las imágenes si no me equivoco
desde camboya en lo cual estamos todos
sufriendo las consecuencias de esta
grave crisis de residuos que estamos
viviendo se habla mucho de crisis a
nivel mundial pero estamos literalmente
siendo tapados por basuras por residuos
y el mejor momento para comenzar es hoy
si eso es lo que siempre intentamos dar
un mensaje positivo y de aliento desde
la organización a nivel mundial y como
bien dices con todos los partners que
nos están apoyando y que estamos
trabajando en forma conjunta para
remediar esta terrible situación esta
pandemia que estamos viviendo de
residuos ahora mauro cuáles son los
residuos o contaminantes que más se
encuentran en estas limpiezas y cuál ha
sido la receptividad de todas las
personas que participan en esta limpieza
por supuesto hemos tenido en la edición
del año pasado en lo que va a ser la
edición del 2021 y comienza hoy mismo en
algunos países de asia
cada vez más voluntarios que forman
parte a pesar de la situación del cob y
con las diferentes alternativas que
estamos ofreciendo para que todo sea
dentro de un ambiente de salubridad y de
seguridad siempre la seguridad va
primero los voluntarios se acercan en
masa para colaborar porque ven observan
la realidad del problema entonces una
vez que podemos localizar que podemos
ser conscientes de la situación de la
trágica situación que está enfrentando
no solo el planeta sino nosotros como
comunidad tomamos acción por mano propia
entonces es eso es el let's do it vamos
a hacerlo es realmente dediquemos a
pensar unos minutos unas horas de
nuestro día para poder remediar la
situación en términos ambientales
mauri con que empresas trabajen como es
la colaboración con los gobiernos de
diferentes países del mundo
y con empresas son muchísimas prefiero
no nombrar a las ahora que ellos mismos
participen y que muchas más empresas se
sumen ahora bien todas las empresas
están invitadas a participar lo único
que también pedimos que esto no sea
solamente para el día mundial de
limpieza y que todas sus acciones a lo
largo del año con sus voluntarios con
sus empleados puedan generar acciones
dentro de sus compañías y que esto
también se muestre se evidencia en sus
familias o sea en la familia de los
trabajadores con respecto a los
gobiernos cada vez más son los que se
suman de hecho y tengo que mencionarlo
el gobierno de estonia donde esto
comenzó como bien has dicho en el 2008
hasta el primer ministro y la presidenta
hoy por este año van a formar parte
entonces esto no es algo atípico es algo
que en estonia se viene haciendo del
2008 y cada vez más sectores públicos a
nivel gobierno participan y se involucra
tengamos en cuenta que la problemática
ambiental está siendo cada vez más en el
tapete en todas las noticias por lo cual
los residuos también deben serlo no
solamente hablar de cambio climático y
sustentabilidad sino también resolver
situaciones
y por hoy nos están tapando literalmente
por ultimo mauro como pueden hacer las
personas que se quieren unir a esta
iniciativa y también le pregunto si se
pueden hacer donaciones
no no no como donaciones si preferimos
que trabajen codo a codo con las
empresas los trabajadores y los
voluntarios en cada uno de los países de
los 180 países que estamos trabajando
totalmente pues mauro gracias por su
tiempo y por estar aquí en 5 minutos con
de france 24 hasta una próxima
oportunidad y ustedes los invito a que
continúe con nosotros hay mucho más para
ver aquí en nuestro canal hasta pronto
[Música]